In 'The Matrix Resurrections,' is Trinity
the One?
And why does Jada Pinkett-Smith's Niobe seem
to be so old?
Let's plug into the Matrix and dig into the
details."
Since the first trailer's release, speculation
has circulated as to what Jonathan Groff's
involvement in "The Matrix: Resurrections"
would be.
His character was seen near the end of the
initial preview in a mic-dropping meta moment:
"Okay, we're going back to where it all started.
Back to the matrix!"
In that first trailer, the character certainly
gave off a huge "bad guy" vibe.
Now, following this all-new preview, there's
a lot to suggest that the former "Mindhunter"
could well be an upgraded version of the Agents
that Neo once faced before.
Firstly, there's the near pitch-perfect impersonation
of Hugo Weaving's straight-faced baddie in
a necktie, Agent Smith.
He also refers to Neo as "Mr. Anderson," the
name that Smith used to mock Neo's transition
to digital messiah.
Could his part in this new chapter of "The
Matrix" be an advanced version of the Smith
program?
One that saw the real world and managed to
make his way back to the prison he couldn't
stand the smell of?
If so, it suits Groff perfectly.
Neo may be the chosen one, but Trinity gets
a fair amount of attention in the final trailer
for "The Matrix Resurrections."
Compared to the previous two sequels, the
trailers suggest that this time around, Neo's
not the one in the driver's seat.
There's one line in the second trailer that
seems to make this clear:
"The most important choice of Neo's life is
not his to make."
This is followed by Neo stating,
"She believed in me.
It's my turn to believe in her."
Since Neo's first awakening as The One happened
because Trinity believed in him, it seems
safe to assume that Neo's referring to Trinity
here.
The remainder of the trailer also centers
heavily on her, and we don't think that's
an accident.
If this is a new version of the Matrix, is
it possible that Trinity's the new One?
Seen briefly in the last teaser with a copy
of "Alice in Wonderland," Priyanka Chopra's
as-yet unnamed character has a few more things
to say on the film's current events and, more
importantly, Neo's involvement in it all.
But who is this person to have a say in our
hero's future?
Is she new to the scene, or could she be someone
from his past?
One common theory is that Chopra Jonas is
playing an older version of Sati, a character
who originally appeared in "The Matrix Revolutions."
Sati was a program that looked like a child,
built without purpose by her parents who were
smuggled into The Matrix by the Oracle.
For her part, the Oracle believed Sati would
play a massive part in the future for both
the machines and humanity.
Could this be the role the Oracle saw for
her?
"That's it.
You've got to use your hands."
"Why?"
"Cookies need love like everything does.”
Debuting in "The Matrix Reloaded," Niobe,
portrayed by Jada Pinkett-Smith, played a
critical role in the events of the second
two "Matrix" films.
Although her character took on a supporting
role in the movies, she was featured prominently
as a main character in the video game tie-in
"Enter the Matrix," which was written by the
Wachowskis and is considered to be canonical.
The 2003 video game fleshed out the character,
along with her co-pilot Ghost, and showed
how critical their actions were in making
sure Neo, Morpheus, and Trinity's plans come
to fruition.
Niobe was able to survive the onslaught of
the machines at the end of "Matrix Revolutions,"
and her character embraced the newfound peace
between machines and humanity.
In the new "Matrix Resurrection" trailer,
we see a woman who seems to be an older Niobe
— a much older Niobe, which raises questions
about when this sequel is supposed to take
place.
Whether she's the Niobe we remember or a computer
program or a new character entirely played
by the same actress, we have no idea.
Either way, no shot in the trailer makes it
clearer just how much time has passed since
the story of "The Matrix" started.
"I don't know if you're ready to see what
I want to show you."
In the original "Matrix" films, scenes taking
place within the Matrix tend to be tinted
green, whereas scenes set in the real world
are largely dark blue or gray in color.
This was especially prominent in "Reloaded"
and "Revolutions," when both Neo and the audience
were fully aware of the artificial nature
of the Matrix's reality.
In the trailers for "The Matrix Resurrections,"
though, the shots that seem to take place
in a version of the Matrix are saturated with
a distinct blue color.
Rather than recalling the cold and gray real
world of the original three "Matrix" films,
this color seems more representative of the
blue pill famously presented to Neo in the
first "Matrix" film.
"You take the blue pill, the story ends, you
wake up in your bed and you believe whatever
you want to believe."
Since the first trailer for "The Matrix Resurrections"
showed Neo taking what seemed to be a daily
dose of blue pills, it seems like this movie's
false reality might be an artificial world
that, for Neo at least, is in need of constant
reinforcement.
One exception to the predominance of blue
shades in what seems to be the Matrix occurs
during a haunting shot in the second trailer
that seems to show Neo walking off the edge
of a building.
In this shot, Neo looks to be choosing to
defy the reality around him with a leap of
faith, as desperate onlookers scream and reach
for him.
As Neo walks toward the sunlight on the left
side of the frame, the clothing on the people
and the colors of the chairs behind them seem
to be an equal mix of red and blue, perhaps
indicating Neo's gradual turn away from a
blue-pilled way of thinking.
This red-blue mix also seems to be at play
in the trailer's shots of the red pods that
hold the bodies of people plugged into the
Matrix -- the towers of human batteries that
Morpheus originally described in the first
movie.
In the trailer's shots of these people pods,
the colors blue and red co-mingle, seeming
to demonstrate a clash between the false reality
of the machines, and the real world beyond
the Matrix.
While the fourth Matrix movie seems to be
a continuation of the previous story, it appears
that it will once again involve the deconstruction
of a false reality in which Neo and Trinity
have become somehow entangled.
"Maybe this isn't the story we think it is."
The reality that Neo seems to be trapped in
during "The Matrix Resurrections" could very
well represent a state of blissful ignorance,
with the machines or some other force keeping
Neo sedated in a fake world for reasons we
don't know yet.
That idea of ignorance would also explain
why Neo doesn't seem to have any memory of
the events we know occurred with him before.
From what we've seen of "Resurrections," making
Neo remember what happened in the past seems
to be key to the story's future.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.